they said milestone in the coronavirus
fight the AP now learning that more than
200,000 confirmed deaths worldwide from
the corona virus that is according to
the Johns Hopkins University researchers
who are keeping track of this and now we
dig into the economic destruction that
has been caused by the corona virus not
only around the world but specifically
here in the United States we bring in
the labor secretary Eugene Scalia we
appreciate you being here sir thank you
and dig into those projections for
unemployment quarterly by the CBO that
came out q1 14% which were already over
in through 2 to 16% q3 11.7% it is hard
to imagine as Jillian said that things
are gonna get worse for people being
laid off
well we released at the Labor Department
some difficult numbers this week to
showing that now more than 26 million
Americans have followed for unemployment
in the last 5 weeks that's just hard to
see and we recognize the sacrifice that
our that's being made by so many
Americans across the country to beat
this virus and what makes it even more
painful is remembering how strong the
economy was yeah month and a half ago we
just had an exceptional economy with
record low unemployment and rising wages
and and and the mission now is to get
back there I do think that a silver
lining is is how we got here this was a
public health response not a underlying
weakness to the economy and I think we
have time now to get back to where we
were as we reopen there's a lot of worry
though that the response to this is
good-hearted and well-meaning as it is
he is putting in some fundamental
weaknesses to the economy the cares Act
means states can extend unemployment
benefits by up to 13 weeks 600
additional dollars of unemployment
benefits for up to 39 weeks on top of
the unemployment benefits you're getting
from the state in states allowed to
provide maximum flexibility for
reimbursing employers and I've talked to
a number of small business owners who
say this is basically an incentive for
people to stay on the unemployment rolls
and is going to make the recovery slower
is it time to maybe take a scalpel to
some of these
acts that have been done well I think it
was important for the president to move
so quickly as he did to help Americans
who are being put out about him being
put out there on it right now and and
that's what the Care Act did let me
emphasize Leland that you don't get
unemployment
if you quit work because you want to get
that unemployment check it you need to
be laid off against which those jobs
become available to workers we at the
Labor Department of expect the workers
to leave unemployment and go back to
jobs and we've been working closely with
the states to help the people who are
making more on unemployment than they
would back washing dishes or landscaping
et cetera are gonna stay on unemployment
they're gonna take less money to go back
to work we're keeping an eye on that
again they've been working closely with
the states underscoring for them the
importance that as we reopen they take a
look at employers that are saying hey
we're ready to bring people back and and
work with the employer community to make
sure that happens I also don't think
it's going to make sense for individual
workers to pass on a job for a couple
extra months of unemployment benefits -
but we'll keep an eye on it meanwhile
we've got the we finally got the
Paycheck protection Graham refunded
which is a program I've thought is so
important what it does is provides loans
to small business to help them keep
their workers on payroll so again
Leyland as we reopen those workers are
they're ready to go I was sad I hate to
interrupt you but I want to get to this
this last point this was about now
between 2.5 trillion and 3 trillion
dollars that has been spent so far on
the coronavirus handouts bailouts call
them whatever you you want to say that's
a lot of money is there a time when
we're gonna have to start thinking about
how much all of this costs not just
spend it whim because this is a crisis
to two quick points to lean first on
paycheck protection on that is a good
program I'm glad it's being funded again
I was saddened to see the Democratic
leadership delay that for a few days and
I thought during that time of the small
businesses
workers that weren't getting that
support they need looking forward I
think you're right we need to be careful
and remember that part of what gave us
that very robust economy we had was a
lack of unnecessary burdens restrictions
constraints on business free markets
free Americans are going to be very
important to this rebound to and as we
look toward any potential future action
out of Congress we need to avoid it
becoming a frenzy of new obligations
restrictions and the like we need to let
our economy come back to life it's an
important question in terms of what the
recovery is going to look like and you
just pointed out some of the things that
might influence that is as we look at
the CBO numbers the discussion of this
v-shaped recovery where things are just
gonna snap back when everybody reopens
that seemed feasible and perhaps even
realistic when everything was going to
shut down for 15 days to slow the spread
we've been at this now for 45 plus days
is there a reason to set expectations a
little bit differently in terms of what
this recovery is gonna look like it's
uncharted territory we know that we've
never seen unemployment numbers this
high but on the other hand we've never
had them taken as a purposeful public
health measure there was a poll
yesterday from AP showing that 78% of
Americans unemployed expect to return to
their jobs I really like that number but
you're right Leland it is important to
be very focused now in the reopening so
we can reconnect workers to jobs while
those jobs are still there mr. secretary
we appreciate your time on a Saturday I
know you've got a busy day of meetings
as well coming up and we appreciate it
we'll have you back as this continues my
pleasure thank you sir